so I gotta ask you this question I feel
like it's pretty obvious but [__] Mary
kill between stand-up comedy making
music and Joey roses I mean I'd [__]
Joey roses because it's it's you know
it's fun being in the bar in Sandwich
business but it's a different kind of
work that I hadn't been used to in a
long time it's not the Arts it's like no
it's a business there's a building there
and he needs to make money but I am
attracted to it I want to [__] I mean
I'd marry the band only because you know
I listen to music and every day you know
constantly not con but consistently I
don't listen to stand up every day you
know right so I guess I'd have to kill
stand up but we had a good run 23 years
you know whatever like